[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
why brad pitt wants his day in court
with ex-wife angelina jolie plus federal
prosecutors recommend a hefty sentence
for disgraced r b singer r kelly and i
filed for divorce last week mike should
be getting papers served soon
i am so sad so hurt and torn apart a
look inside the journal of a florida
woman accused of murdering her step dad
turned husband but first never in my
wildest dreams did i think that as
a police officer as a law enforcement
officer i would find myself
in the middle of a battle capitol
officers on the scene recount the
carnage of the january 6 insurrection
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer for the
first time the january 6 house select
committee holds a hearing during prime
time showing never before seen footage
of the u.s capitol's insurrection
after months of investigation the house
select committee presented its findings
thursday in the first of a series of
hearings set for this month their
findings include interviews with more
than a thousand people involved with the
insurrection and examination of videos
taken during the event former president
donald trump faces allegations of
attempting to overturn the 2020
presidential election results after now
president joe biden won the election on
january 6 2021 a mob of trump supporters
stormed the united states capital in
washington d.c disrupting the joint
session of congress gathered to count
electoral votes
five people died during the day's event
and nearly 140 people were injured
including many police officers a video
shown during thursday's hearing outlined
a timeline of events
i hope mike is going to do the right
thing i hope so
mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
because you'll never
take back our country with weakness
[Applause]
cruiser 50 it does look like we're gonna
have an ad hoc march stepping off here
mike pence i hope you're gonna stand up
for the good of our constitution
49 hours declaring it a riot
[Applause]
one advisor trying to breach and get to
the capitol
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a breach of the capital breach
of the capital to
during thursday's hearing the committee
heard from capitol officer caroline
edwards who was injured multiple times
during the insurrection from hitting her
head on a concrete stairwell and later
being pepper sprayed and tear gassed
i can just remember
my my breath
catching in my throat
because
i what i saw was just a war scene it was
something like i'd seen out of
the movies
i i couldn't believe my eyes there were
officers on the ground
um
you know
they were bleeding they were throwing up
they were you know they had
i mean i saw friends with blood all over
their faces i was slipping in people's
blood
um
you know i i was
catching people as they fell i you know
i was
it was
carnage
it was chaos
i i can't i can't even
describe
what i saw i never in my wildest dreams
did i think that as
a police officer as a law enforcement
officer i would find myself in the
middle of a battle
joining us today is legal analyst marie
pereira and co-host terry austin marie
yesterday was just an introduction to
what they found in their investigation
without preview what else do you think
we will learn as the weeks go on
i think we're going to learn that the
people there that put their lives at
risk were human beings i think their
opportunity to put more
capital police officers on the stand to
put a face on exactly what happened is
important and i think the timing of it
near the midterm elections is also
important because there are still people
out there who believe donald trump
um lost the election
unfairly and these people are going to
vote and i think during these hearings
we're going to see who is really
responsible who financed these rallies
and who are the insiders that might have
been involved with helping the rioters
even breach the capitol building i'm
interested to see how it's going to pan
out but i think at the end they're going
to educate the public who are going to
be midterm election voters exactly how
donald trump tried to assail america's
democracy with these uh two attempt
terry speaking of donald trump the
committee gathered some incriminating
information against him does congress
have the ability or the power to bring
criminal charges against donald trump
you know what brian that's a good
question they do not have the power to
bring criminal charges but they can make
recommendations to the department of
justice and they've actually done that
before they've recommended that two
trump aides be held in contempt of
congress for failing to cooperate with
their subpoenas so i think this entire
questioning this entire hearing is all
about making sure the people know what
is going on that the public is aware of
what actually occurred on january 6 it
was a very slick presentation they did a
great job and i do think they are
looking at the midterms there'll be more
hearings to follow with more information
after they've led with the timeline of
events
and in texas a year's long mystery has
has some closure after the child of a
couple who went who were the apparent
victims of a homicide in the 1980s is
found alive in 1981 a man and woman's
bodies were found in a wooded area near
houston their identities unknown that is
until 2021 when a group called identity
finders international was able to id the
bodies with the help of genetic
genealogy the florida couple was
identified as tina gail lynn klaus and
harold dean klaus jr the officials
quickly determined the couple had a
daughter named holly but she was not
found with their remains
41 years ago and has been missing since
two years ago the families of harold and
tina began looking for answers wondering
what happened to baby holly and the
couple who were lost last seat heard of
from the 1980s their daughter holly
marie klaus now 40 years old was
recently found in oklahoma as a result
of the collaboration of several agencies
across multiple states the cold case and
missing persons unit with the texas
attorney general's office formed two
years ago made the announcement thursday
along with new information about where
holly's been for the last 40 years
baby holly was left at a church in
arizona and was taken into their care
out of respect for holly and her family
we won't have any further comments or
details regarding that at this time
the family that raised holly are not
suspects in this case
two women who identified themselves as
members of a nomadic religious group
brought holly to the church
they were wearing white robes and they
were barefoot
it is believed that this particular
group traveled around southwestern
united states
including arizona california and
possibly texas
there were sightings of this religious
group around the yuma arizona area in
the early eighties tina lynn klaus and
harold dean klaus were likely murdered
between december 1980 or early january
1981.
we wish holly the best we're grateful
that we've found her
but we must continue with our purpose of
finding
who murdered
this couple
the investigation into the murders of
harold and tina is still ongoing along
with anyone with information is
encouraged to contact the texas attorney
general's cold case and missing persons
unit
still ahead on law and crime daily
federal prosecutors recommend a lengthy
sentence for r b star r kelly but first
i'll look inside the mind of danielle
redmond as jurors hear exercise from the
accused husband killer's diary
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily
testimony begins in the trial of
danielle redlich a florida woman charged
with second-degree murder but is
claiming self-defense in the death of
her husband
michael redlich was stabbed to death
three years ago allegedly by his wife
danielle she says her husband was
abusive and that she killed him in
self-defense the incident happened
january 11 2019 9-1-1 calls from the
next day revealed daniel initially told
dispatchers michael had stabbed himself
and had a heart attack the night before
after the two had an altercation the
couple reportedly had a rocky marriage
and prosecutors said michael wanted a
divorce before he was killed they say
danielle was perusing dating apps while
waiting 11 hours before she called for
help on thursday the lead crime scene
technician took the stand she read a
journal entry written by the defendant
for the jury
did you find journals inside of these
drawers
our detectives did yes and did you
document them at their request yes i did
let's
read
the entry on march 12 2018
i filed for divorce last week mike
should be getting papers served soon
i am so sad so hurt and torn apart
i have had to really dig deep and rely
on faith and my neighbor jan
mike's betrayal a second time with that
nicole woman is the worst hurt ever my
life the last eight years or so has been
so hard scary and unpleasant
michael is moving out april 1st i wish i
could never see him again
i feel like
he if given any opportunity will end up
destroying me totally
he really has done a number on me
terry the witness literally read from
the defendant's diary wouldn't that
statement or all those statements in the
diary be considered hearsay
you know i thought the same thing it is
an out of court statement and it's being
asserted to prove the truth of the
matter so there are multiple exceptions
under the hearsay rule and i'm thinking
that when they argued about this they
probably argued under the exception then
existing mental emotional or physical
condition what that means is that it's a
statement that the declarant makes and
it shows what their existing state of
mind might have been and so i think
that's probably the exception that got
this particular piece of evidence into
evidence so i'm not sure why the judge
let it in but and you know it's in there
now so we'll see if it helps yeah at the
top of my head it could also be a
statement by a party opponent you you
can you can have your statements used
against you if you're not mirandized in
certain situations but it's probably one
of the two marie the journal entry
sounds like
she's a victim of domestic violence
doesn't that help danielle's case so why
would the prosecution have it read in
court
it depends on who's telling the story it
could be that she's a victim of domestic
violence or she has a motive as a
scorned woman
apparently this woman nicole fancied by
her husband for the second time she was
vengeful resentful and capable of murder
because she felt rejected so it depends
on who's telling the story and it
depends on who is in the jury box what
are their life experiences and who are
they going to empathize with it could be
seen both ways
yeah i know a lot of lawyers depending
on the gender of the the victim or the
defendant love the saying hell hath no
fury like and i can see that being used
in a case like this
in florida the penalty phase
re-sentencing trial will move forward
with one defendant instead of two after
an outburst from defendant alan wade
during jury selection
alan wade is one of four people involved
in the deaths of reggie and carol sumner
wade along with michael james jackson
tiffany cole and bruce nixon were
convicted more than a decade ago for
their involvement in the murder cole
argues jackson hatched the plan to break
into the couple's home while they were
away but that plan evolved into killing
them prosecutors argued at the
defendant's trials that the four dug a
hole in a remote wooded spot in georgia
before kidnapping the subners the group
stole from the couple's home then forced
them into the trunk of their own car
they later forced a couple to share
their bank account information before
burying them alive wade jackson and cole
were all sentenced to death for the
murder nixon took a plea deal and
pleading guilty to second-degree murder
wade and jackson will be re-sentenced
separately after a change in florida law
which requires a unanimous jury decision
for the death penalty
coming up on law and crime daily fresh
off the heels of the johnny depp amber
heard trial could another pair of
celebrity exes be headed to court plus
months after a federal conviction
prosecutors recommend a sentence and
hefty fine for singer r kelly
[Music]
welcome back disgraced r b singer r
kelly could face more than 25 years in
prison a sentence recommended by federal
prosecutors in new york in september
robert sylvester kelly was convicted of
all nine counts of racketeering
including sexual exploitation of a child
kidnapping bribery and a separate charge
of sex trafficking the conviction of the
artist known for his anthem i believe i
can fly was a pivotal moment of the
metoo movement with prosecutors at trial
calling kelly's operation of managers
and aides recruiting girls and young
women a criminal enterprise in a
following wednesday federal prosecutors
said kelly should be sentenced to 25
years and be fined 50 to 250 thousand
dollars saying kelly used his fame and
popularity to quote prey upon children
and young women for his own sexual
gratification they wrote that kelly
committed his crimes and avoided
punishment for almost 30 years and needs
to be held accountable kelly's attorneys
argued that the maximum sentence under
the federal guidelines should be 17
years not 25. kelly is scheduled to be
sentenced june 29th in new york
all right terry so prosecutors want 25
years of defense says the maximum kelly
should get under the sentencing
guideline is 17. what do you think the
judge will do with these two different
numbers
that's a great question brian listen the
prosecution is seeking the maximum under
the law but what the defense is saying
is that if you use these federal
sentencing guidelines that maximum
should be reduced to 17 and what they do
with the guidelines they look at two
factors they look at the offense level
and they look at the criminal history
and what the defense is arguing here is
yes this is the high offense but low
criminal history and the calculation
should be less than the 25 it should be
17 but the judge to answer your question
is probably going to ignore the federal
sentencing guidelines because they are
just that guidelines they are not
mandatory they're discretionary and i
think the judge is probably going to
throw the book at r kelly yeah and i
expect if he does that expect an appeal
by his defense as well
prosecutors also want kelly to be fined
50 to 250 000 so
where does that money go and what if he
can't pay
well you know as a public defender they
put on these surcharges and fines to to
deter and punish if he doesn't have the
money to pay then it goes into
collections and they can seize whatever
assets he has they can um forfeit put
liens on his properties and things like
that and usually they say that you know
the money goes to support court systems
support government operations police
sanitation infrastructure and it usually
also goes to victim support funds to
help victims of crimes to get over their
uh their damage from the criminal
activity yeah i kind of see especially
with a case like this with so many
sexual assault victims that money may be
earmarked more so for that than anything
else thank you both for that breakdown
though when we come back could
brangelina soon be headed to a jury
trial why brad pitt says ex-wife
angelina jolie made a move to
intentionally harm him by selling off
shares of their wine company
[Music]
welcome back academy award-winning
actors and a former couple brad pitt and
angelina jolie could soon be headed to
court as pitt calls for a trial by jury
alleging his ex-wife intentionally
harmed their wine company
it all stems from the once shared
chateau mobile a 164 million dollar
company and vineyard in the south of
france before their 2016 divorce the
couple equally split shares of the
business after that pitt says they made
a pact not to sell out their shares
without their partner's consent but pitt
says jolie ignored the agreement that
would allow him to buy out her 50
percent share or refuse the sale his
team alleges jolie unlawfully sold her
half of the business to yuri shuffler
a russian businessman court documents
filed by pitt last week alleged jolie
worked to undermine her husband by
forcing him into business with a quote a
stranger with poisonous associations and
intentions at the same time some fans
speculate that jolie may file suit
against the fbi for its investigation of
a 2016 incident involving pitt and the
couple's oldest son maddox who was 15
years old at the time the incident
happened on a private plane meaning it's
fbi jurisdiction the organization
concluded there was no wrongdoing on
pitt's part in the way of a domestic
violence five days later jolie filed for
divorce
marissa the deal is done angelina jolie
sold her shares so if brad pitt wins the
case what can he get back to make him
whole
if he can prove the damages and i think
it's really hard to make extreme
commentary until we have full access to
the terms of that agreement between both
parties to see what they intended and
did she in fact violate their intent to
share this together and not sell her
shares and what if anything did the
contract have but the party who breached
he will be seeking damages
claiming you damaged me by forcing me to
do business with this person that i
don't know and i lost money and he has
to prove the damages and that's what
he'll be going after to recoup damages
caused by her unlawful decision and
breaking the terms of the contract yeah
was this a contract was this a handshake
or this a verbal agreement it all is
going to come down to what we see in
trial and that's my question for you
terry are we gearing up to see another
debt be heard like trial or is it going
to be completely different because it's
about property and not defamation
honestly i don't think there will ever
be another trial like that be heard that
was the most watched trial i've seen
certainly in a long time but i do think
both brad and angelina are famous movie
stars and if in fact this is a case that
goes to court before jury and if we are
able to have cameras in that courtroom i
do think that millions of people will be
watching it they are famous and
listening to the details is something
that i think most public people want to
know about it won't be as exciting
because we're talking about property
we're not talking about defamation but
we will get an inside scoop as to what
the conversations were was everything
documented and we might even you know
hear testimony from other people that
might just
everyone so we'll see
all right maybe law and crime will let
us all drink wine as we cover it as well
we can only hope well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you